tell me a little bit about the the
experience of being in Forbes being on
the cover of Forbes was it what kind of
response did you get from from it look I
mean it was it was a real thing guys and
it was real and it was real for me and
for us across a few dimensions the most
important one was our ability to attract
brilliant people to come and work for us
I mean that is our single that as far as
I'm concerned will be the deciding
factor of whether or not we will
ultimately be successful if we can
continue building a brilliant team of
engineers that really appreciates this
creative community that we're building
products for our ability to find more of
those people any opportunity we have to
tell that story and tell that story in a
forum where they can see that the
business world appreciates this to that
this has some place in the world beyond
just you know certain you know kind of
self serving this community that we and
the engineers we're trying to track care
about but that this can be big and
important out there in the world that
has been those those moments have been
essential for us bringing in that talent
and that was I was measurable after this
story well the other piece was just look
it we were raising money at the
beginning of the year the rate of people
just proactively reaching out to us the
rate of people that were you know
frantically calling us back in to hang
out with them and the the number of
important decision makers that were
being included in those meetings before
and after your coverage was again
measurable so you know this stuff it
really really matters particularly to
folks like us who are still trying to
it's not i wouldn't say trying to prove
anything so much is just trying to tell
our story trying to show the world how
what we're doing is really important and
how it's starting to work and
the truth is those forums where we have
the opportunity to really tell our story
not just answer questions about
entrepreneurship raising money or the
just sort of meta business stuff that
kind of comes along with trying to build
something like what we're trying to do
at tumblr and those forms are few and
far between and this was this was really
meaningful I look I give you guys a lot
of credit for for everything and as
that's happened since I've a check for a
hundred million dollars